Labour's shadow brexit secretary circus
dharma is with us now good morning big
day today it finally feels like crunch
time there's one I mean particularly as
you know we've been fighting to have a
meaningful vote for the best part of two
years now and it's sort of taken on the
life of its own so here we arrive with
that vote coming at seven o'clock this
evening so it's a very important
significant day you've got what you
fought for and that meaningful vote as
you said happening tonight yeah and
we've crunched the numbers Theresa May
expected to lose that vote by up to 200
votes tonight
if that happens does the note of
no-confidence request come in from you
straight away well I don't want to get
into the numbers that she may lose but I
think she will lose and we'll have to
see just what the numbers are jeremy
corbyn's made it very clear that we do
intend to put down a motion of
no-confidence the question is when nor
if and it would be Jeremy's decision but
he's already indicated it'll be soon so
we'll have to just wait and see all my
but but I think something else has to
happen tonight genuinely and that is
that the Prime Minister really needs to
make a statement before she leaves the
house tonight I don't think she can just
walk out of the chamber we've been
discussing whether she should make a
statement other plan beers in three days
or seven days I don't think she's got
that amount of time she needs to stand
up at 7:30 this evening and make that
statement a substantial statement saying
this is what I intend to do next because
that's the question that everybody's
asking and we need to know what her
approaches and she's really got a choice
is she gonna say I'm still gonna try and
ran through my deal I'll bring it back
in a week or two weeks or three weeks
which would be the wrong calls or is she
gonna say I now recognize I've got this
wrong there's got to be the space for
other options whether that's a general
election or something else there's got
to be the space for that it's
interesting isn't it because and you're
talking about to resume ramming through
this deal she's not listening and and
labour saying that the premise is in
denial over this and she will lose this
vote but a lot of people are saying you
know Labour's talk of a no-confidence
vote is the Labour Party being in denial
as well because it's something you can't
win conceptive MPs won't vote to bring
down their own government a DUP
a number of things about that the first
is that but for the fixed term
Parliament act which we passed not so
long ago everybody would expect the
prime minster to be going to the country
tomorrow for years and years and years
in the United Kingdom if the government
lost a massive vote and this would be
the biggest possibly in history but
certainly for decades you'd go to the
country so the only reason that we're
even I think brilliant confidence motion
is because the Prime Minister is
clinging on to the to the act that
prevents that happening as a matter of
convention that's the first thing the
second thing is if I was saying to you
today oh we're not going to bring a
confidence motion you'll be some why not
that's the thing that should happen is
you're testing the comedy's motion it's
all about the timing and that's because
you're unsure when you can actually win
it you're probably car course you are I
mean no no opposition would say yeah we
know we're going to win it on this day
and we have to make a judgment call
there are lots of folks the government
has lost in the last six months that it
didn't want to lose and if we bring a
confidence motion I would invite
everybody who doesn't want to No Deal
outcome to vote on that let's have a
general look from where the EP members
indicated to you that they would support
you and they come to me and indicate
their support but what you have seen in
recent weeks of months is different
groups of MPs across the house combining
to get results so as I say the challenge
there's always a double challenge to me
which is if we think we're going to put
a confidence vote you say why you're
gonna do it and if we say we're not
gonna do it you say why aren't you gonna
do it then you would another challenge
you know there's the challenge with this
vote tonight there was the challenge
ever no confidence and general elections
which you know when people look at it
realistically at the home they think
well Teresa may he's not gonna get this
deal you're not gonna get your general
election what about if Teresa may lost
and reached across the aisle to the
Labor Party who said okay let's work
together to come to some form of
agreement that will get this through so
we have a plan that would Labour be
prepared to work with Teresa medical we
have to see what approach she takes if
she says I'm not going to try and run my
deal through I am gonna create a space
where Parliament can look at the options
and start to have a much greater
involvement then we would be interested
that has to happen because
we're going to avoid no deal there has
to be something that Parliament can
coalesce around and couldn't agree on so
the Prime Minister's attitude at 7:30
this evening is going to dictate the
question of what happens next
but Parliament if she doesn't we'll take
control you've already seen that last
two or three weeks all the arguments
with the speaker etc that's about MPs
sake we are not going to be shut out of
this process yeah actually it's
interesting you talk about MPs not
wanting to be shut out and having a say
got some Twitter questions for you
Robin John Pittock asked never mind the
MPs confidence the Prime Minister what
about the UK citizens confidence with
Parliament now a lot of people will be
watching this folks at home tonight
going MPs aren't voting in my interest
for the breaks that I want they're
voting in their own interest whether it
be they want a general election or
whether it won't they want to get their
deal through yeah I know a lot of people
will think that a lot of people say
they're bored or frustrated with the
process we need to look at the deal and
ask ourselves a simple question is this
good enough for our country because
we're talking about the future
relationship with the EU if the answer
that is no we have to vote against it
and there's no good me coming back in a
year or two and you say to me well why
on earth didn't you oppose that deal I
said well people a bit frustrated and
bored with the process we've got a duty
to assess it and if it's not good enough
we have to vote against it and then we
have to look at the other options we've
got a duty to do that